okay sad guys unless odd people just
kept [ __ ] calling and I was like what
the [ __ ] but what what is this a
tutorial like this the [ __ ] end of
the game you gotta be [ __ ] ridiculous
so never for those people like we're I
mean I call a diversion
skel recorder what the [ __ ] it is
san help
okay now that you grant Lockwood we're
the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] oh great on until
right now this [ __ ] [ __ ] has like
started them now I bet come on okay and
try to forget the best plan here if I
just sure just go hand with this and I
guess I might also have to pointing to
it okay here we go
like that [ __ ] that's how we do it any
other study okay um puck is a skill
recorder I should go behind me and then
upstairs
then I'm like not [ __ ] answer this
place
Morgan we're in life support now it's
all clear
there's normal across the board I lost
some good people fighting the black
boxes and dad wasn't here if you see him
before I do
make him pay well this lady is very late
holy [ __ ] that I like mrs. whole [ __ ]
floor
now I definitely broke that screen
dr. you Morgan I was afraid you would
make it the subject dog has been secured
I believe I've isolated the correct
neural mod it is essential we say as
little as possible of what has happened
on the station and focus on the
situation the memory says should resort
to field training and react accordingly
it was never one to question orders
anyone you are Morgan remember if this
works say nothing we donor or scan real
quick
[Music]
when extracted those memories should
revert back to the inception date and he
should forget his assignment here if
you're having second thoughts performing
the extraction can't set us back any
more than we are but who are you Morgan
your father's asking about you and Alex
I was supposed to report to him about
for retrieval after malting up where am
I
uh I'm at my restraint commander door
I am dr. Egret chief physician here
you've I've seen your face in the
company directory Alex is at the
discredited parapsychologist ah
commander dull you've suffered a severe
head injury as a result of a crisis here
on the station we need to evacuate at
once but we we couldn't leave without
you
are you able to pilot the shuttle what
yes of course I can pilot wait what
emergency
is this Argus installation where's
Casper I'm afraid there's no time to
explain we need to get to the shuttle
bay and prepare for departure transed
our mandate doctor you can confirm of
course Morgan you look like [ __ ]
all right let's get daddy's precious
child off the station Transtar what
black box me
just need to check your bike we want our
pilot to think there's nothing wrong
with me Chad lead the way Morgan we'll
catch up it's my design that I can
predict what you're going to do fairly
often and yet this turn of events with
Dahle I'm impressed and surprised you've
managed to find a way to remaining crew
on Pelican up here Omega classical
freighter radiation diagnosing please
stand clear about this questionnaire at
the front desk so where am I
- [ __ ] is over mr. Yu the steady vas I
worked down in cargo the fact is we've
been stealing from you sir it started
small just blowing harmless contraband
on and off the station farmers food not
on the safe list I don't know maybe you
don't pay your texting Hardware enough
but Lily got ambitious after a while
started stealing neuro mods fabrication
plans telling them to Transtar rivals
yeah we were meant for a sake mr. you
casual has got our IP now Lily made me
modify some of the old alarm panels
around tell us so we could use them as
dead-drops
certain a few of them still have company
property three Tatsu the wrench will pop
it open anyway I just wanted to say you
know I never meant for things to get out
of hand it just took on a life of its
own
but that I'd like to make it right any
way I can
that's all
okay hey guy get the [ __ ] out of here
I'm looking away
alright alright alright
Henry [ __ ] listen to the trick
scripted wait
DeVries Alex what is that what is this
in here what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] up ship flying out
I cannot equip that message
I need a bridge
hmm ballast hold on
I'm encrypting the rest of this okay dr.
Cole's already wiped the recording of
Morgan's breakdown off his computer the
last copy is hidden in his office I'm
not going back you'll have to get it
yourself a seat b8c good luck
[ __ ] [ __ ] am i gettin over there
I guess I'm a long way the [ __ ] happen
here that's [ __ ] RFI
yeah [ __ ] - I never able to contact
you scary Oh silly I've been in here
like 20 times
[ __ ] there's a [ __ ] coming I like like
like much luckily I don't guess I wish I
think love that's what we will deliver
supplemental seminar on neural
connectomes in the lobby training center
later this week holy [ __ ] sounded wrong
[Music]
[Music]
Quincy diagnosing look like you had a
rough day I did a lot of patient
experience questionnaire so I get serve
you better next time
this [ __ ] Luther glass what happened
here okay okay
holy [ __ ] hello hacking is like weather
the best tool it's a whole tower game
like I don't know how you someone get to
the game about acting after you
okay I didn't see you there and I ditch
welcome maybe I can only please contact
a qualified engineer ah that day
okay tell me about the dream the dream
yes it's a moment here it's always in my
lab and we're standing in front all up
in the glass are you alone you won't
will be yes what do you see in the glass
who are you nothing at first I don't
want to turn it on but I can't help it
I turned it on when I do it's like the
heart of a black hole
an immense darkness there's something
swimming in the black I catch glimpses
at ACPA they feel as though it wants to
come through onto my side I have to turn
off the glass before it sees me but I
always wait before I can what does it
look like the shape in the glass oh yeah
nothing does it look like this image
here dr. Covino
does it look like this go so know that I
don't do are you sure oh where did you
get that twice well I have you been
spying on me
I don't want to talk to you anymore [ __ ]
a CBAC
addict
and I socket three do this okay okay
come on come on good evening Talos as a
reminder I reckon L must complete
monthly physicals during their stay
aboard Talos one dr. DeVries promises to
make them as quick and painless as
possible
okay let me just see what it is a CB AC
a/c
be a sick
let's save the [ __ ] just mm-hmm you seem
frustrated I have months they're just
gone I've been listening to the logs
reading the research playing catch-up do
you know how many times similar just
compare cheated please contact a
qualified engineer time does it always
go the same way not always what does
that mean what do you think it means
well I think it means you should be
concerned as my counselor you left
yourself a message would you like to
listen to it no I think it would help I
said no that's not me why do you say
that I don't know I I just know you
agreed to this this was all your idea
yours and Alex's I didn't agreed any of
this all right that morning is not me I
would never do you know what's going on
in psychotronics do you if I did if I
couldn't say you know that what do you
know about that - we shouldn't talk
about them not without your brother
present them you do know you snake how
can you sit there Morgan take a deep
breath
here I don't want a pill I want this
station shut down I want her Morgan I
said no okay I'm going to call Alex
okay that thing done
yeah it's not sure really get this line
[ __ ] okay where is there like an airlock
okay I got an idea before I go to see
what's-his-face I'm going to go get
Grant Lockwood
because I know that batchest I'll float
it out there let's pull it out that the
all game we might as well just get them
before he doesn't I think crazy what the
[ __ ] is that
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I can actually go into the back
room real quick
[Music]
now we're hit okay let's get this [ __ ]
okay let's get him
I'll be looking for hands all guy okay
microgravity to check okay
[Music]
I would have never found that match
[Music]
you
okay
take a quick look same as always
all right come on
okay I'm nearly up I'm happy I'm okay
all right let us see let me Italia maybe
yeah yes channel is
[ __ ] that
okay
I guess that's it okay so cute actually
in there no he's [ __ ] ever in there
that's what happens if I just [ __ ]
wave Morgan don't I'm only a shallow
copy of you and I know better than to
abandon tell us one if you leave now
you're only delaying the inevitable
where do you think the Titan will go
next huh huh boy I don't understand how
you got the launch key to that escape
pod all the ways the tests could have
changed you this was the last one I
expected he's just quitting adios
[ __ ] I got mine
[Music]
oh yeah I got mine
what if I just ended the [ __ ] let's
play series right here this isn't the
one
Morgan don't I'm only a shallow copy of
you and I know better than to abandon
tell us one if you leave now you're only
delaying the inevitable where do you
think the Tyson will go next is that
you're actually going to be in here or
outside yes
okay I promised you my arm in cake all I
ask is you hear me up first and you can
both towels one two pieces if that's
what you think is best
I don't think you'll do it I know
because I used to think we couldn't be
trusted to play with fire without
burning a house girl like you convinced
me
you showed me anything was possible a
lot even if the price was steep that
part of you is still in there
we can make your straight Morgan but
those leeches on the transplant board of
directors not mom and dad you and I just
like we planned
[ __ ] they said we have the data to
confirm what you suspected the coral is
broadcasting in total signal secret
message ah stop yeah
pocket how are you
well here we are hopefully you'll never
have to listen to this recording but if
you do and something unfortunate sin to
me I suspect you've seen enough by now
to abandon the nurse destroying tell us
why I've always been the one who thought
we couldn't be trusted to play with fire
without burning the house down but you
convinced me that we could do anything
we met okay
sexy let's do the fish
now thank you
today nap are interlocking I promised
your my are mooncake all I ask is you'll
hear me out first and you can both tell
us one two pieces if that's what you
think is best
I don't think you'll do it I know
because I used to think we couldn't be
trusted to play with fire without
burning the house down but you convinced
me
you showed me anything was possible even
if the price was steep that part of you
is still in there we can make it a cycle
there are those leeches on the trend
stock Board of Directors not mom and dad
you and I and just like we planned we
want the data to confirm what you
suspected coral is broadcasting a neural
signal at time secret message reaching
to the stars what I want to know is what
is the message and who is listening to
it I think you know ever since we first
tested the type in neural mods you've
known this fabrication plan is for the
no wave device prototype you can see it
will hijack the coral signal and use it
to deliver a massive shock there every
type and organism is once again take it
and the army key I gave poor what more
guys
what stop [ __ ] is that
not since integrity
okay holy [ __ ] where are we
what is that
what
okay quick save
oh that's like a throne done okay
and I - I down
holy [ __ ]
and [ __ ] fat [ __ ]
okay tick we don't get
I don't know what the [ __ ] that is
what the [ __ ] is that thank you for dude
hey my effort you could have left me to
die it's more important than ever now
that we finish this White Way take care
of an old white device go ahead for the
bridge as soon as I catch my breath
okay so what the [ __ ] am I supposed to
be doing no way okay where's the closest
fabrication Center
Oh
some guns
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
haha
holy [ __ ] back up
crew quarters [ __ ] there's a master the
map hello shet
yeah yeah I don't not farting it kind of
sucks I get the gut
[ __ ] looking at me
what is that their eagerness what
what the [ __ ]
alright [ __ ] turn on the power okay
[ __ ] yet the skin can be hard going like
not go I Morgan you anticipated the kind
of appeal Alex would make sibling bonds
history you programmed me to refute him
point by point however we can skip that
a type and slow skyscraper is currently
eating Talos one for lunch
ergo Alex is wrong destroy the station
just as you planned the blast will take
the monster down with it destroy the
station but did you hear you
the no way Alex is correct good work and
preserve what we have learned yet we
have to try big way look at alien
outside the station
of course it's a risk but we've seen the
generator work to destroy all these two
murderous species the research fast it's
right block exam I got mine dr. circuit
is one of them as long as we follow mine
destroy this this have slavery last but
not the first
[ __ ] psycho transistor right yeah
sucking trade back
shut
right quite flat cut yet oh [ __ ] like
that
come on come on come on come on
come on let's talk a psychotronic
am i just going in an endless loop
Engineering operator help me
oh shut I was [ __ ] insane
hey if the idea hasn't occurred to you
I'm sure it will eventually don't do it
I can't predict what would happen if you
scan the apex but all my models point to
suffering your birth experience
okay gotta fight a fabricator on this
floor
please be one there is one microgravity
detective the [ __ ] is that
mmm
Molly gravity attacked
Micra grab if it doesn't talk to
what is that
okay
guess I still got a long way
hello
is that in here
all the way for this moment where's the
fabricator
[Applause]
the heart of the car all is in
psychotronics in the original
containment cylinder placing the null
wave device there will override the
entire coral network with our own signal
use your sector scope to locate the
exact spot now
that
come on clients like
okay can my things still detect it or do
I get rid of that
ah [ __ ]
my gravity detected
Construction EVP lighting lying
[Music]
let's do it come to the bridge we can
finish this thing once and for all
okay where's the bridge assume Alex's
plan succeeds then what you're taking a
massive gamble that there aren't more
predators like the titan in the history
of the universe humans that only
recently become self-aware yet you're
going to kick the door open on a much
wider and older cosmic ecology one that
feeds on consciousness - the [ __ ] up
these are shark-infested waters Alex
believes we can be the bigger shark but
what if we're just poor swimmers and now
there's blood in the water that's great
Dean laughs I get that's no way of this
fish
here we go
but
cut a [ __ ] fry [ __ ]
oh the canítö coating and back at the
boutique is token came back with Nakata
okay okay [ __ ]
daddy's got a [ __ ] horrific Avinash I
and I want to finish it but I what I
said
come on God well hello sir
okay let me just say where I gotta go
suck it I gotta go to the fourth floor
that's what kind of [ __ ] is this there's
no like Speedway Pollak [ __ ]
where am I going
a breath early yet we are [ __ ]
that is [ __ ] disgusting
is that correct way to go
no no but I'm gonna I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die
mm-hmm passport II need a pod Oh
microgravity detective
okay I guess I'm back on that way
stop [ __ ]
hello are you here for an appointment
can I just go outside then
like a [ __ ] electrocuted I did
okay oh [ __ ] what's the update on our
patient
commander doll is making a speedy
recovery and we are making our way to
the shuttle bay I created a more than
two or three station order the contr
manal when you doing up to the mobile
device if we're gonna get that signal
off before it's too late
consider the risk Alex's plan if it
works is only a short-term solution none
of us has the right to endanger every
life on earth
if anyone's playing God here it's you
you're a lunatic plan denies every one
of our flight to the stars
you know how neural mods are made the
demand will only increase in the future
Alex and visions many will die for the
benefit of a privileged few I'm not
arguing with a glorified desktop kill it
Morgan sorry Morgan
I won't relinquish control of the
terminal you'll have to destroy me which
means you will be destroying yourself
fine
I'll do with myself
I'm sorry Morgan I didn't want to harm
your brother the directives you gave me
require I do everything in my power to
ensure you destroy Talos one and all the
Tyson detonating the station safeguards
the earth and perhaps provides a small
measure of reparation
I won't relinquish control of the
terminal if you want to activate the
null ways you'll have to kill me
and we're back in New Roman well it's
both an easy answer complicated but at
the same time it is the future today
more importantly our past today this is
the work Transtar does every employee
working together
it's immortality and it is beautiful
Wow I really did it guys so um this was
on seeing a maze again
[Music]
[Music]
okay I just said guys snapchat everyone
oh wow so that was a really good game uh
I don't even know its plugins that I
know there's a live scene at the end of
then so you know
oh [ __ ] don't [ __ ] that I think
literally it was like all it was like
everything the horror genre needed so in
the beginning I was literally afraid
like when you had just a [ __ ] wrench
and you were walking around and like you
saw chairs and you're like holy [ __ ]
like you being afraid of chair and the
cops like holy [ __ ]
and then we actually got weapons here
like a beast then things like it always
made me think just because the others
like so little em I was crazy
so yeah oh [ __ ]
- someone said online that they wish
that there was a lot more ammo so you
can actually just like beat the [ __ ] -
be a ballistic I guess be a fun mode to
do that but chef and also I think the
wyvern jailings has been very similar
givers tech combat [ __ ] any takers back
a lot of phantom - mimics demon got
greater mimics when you got better it
was really good to the second Alaska we
don't on the [ __ ] is that once you
I've never seen that one don't [ __ ] man
target - Joe this song was playing a
little too much so like I think it's
like the 50th I might've done
I want to go on here
[ __ ] it fast and so is this a game
change so much I never remember we're
going up that panicle guy inside the
[ __ ] I'm like swimming pool area that
I was talking on us
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
music beat beat beat beat beat yeah how
I did and then then afternoon dancing
deliberating is a continuous which is
[ __ ] to go insane with them [ __ ] a
curse like these names of weapons I like
[Music]
that's a success I mean he really did a
job we all have a snap yesterday
they're telling you what when we ship
[Music]
Kanaka to Solano fire hybrid that's oh
[ __ ] it's for long is awful
thank you I guess I'll do that anyways
it was insanely and satellite box like
this game apparently after the credit if
you like review how you did which is I
would like to say I went there really
human route I not use any [ __ ] type
in our mods okay cuz it's the wrong
thing to do
[Music]
I think the one what I didn't save zeg
lasted talking I went out onto the
sunning [ __ ] field Grant Lockwood do
but I still remember going back to lobby
like after the coral first shut up and
it was like holy [ __ ] like it crazy that
actually like a balls and you're gone
a lot of [ __ ] worthless holes
yeah
[Music]
BAM
home for now
Tara market
accountant okay
Neji I manage a barber will see that
[ __ ] for this championship for this game
and we all know it uses a bare minimum
call it show underwater koji Oda hear
that a lot
use a lot an amicus really a senior
populations back while I shouldn't
right now
what's going on it's going to take a
look ten years
Mexican train legs and autumn work cut
out for polo channel is only one thing
lock chill out after your audio crew set
the set - using Mexican actors gazelian
access polish actors
client is shedded be fun avoid big
playtester on this game on the CryEngine
does really cool blank video I'm Sheila
chit in like 10 years
I shall look so sad upset okay here we
go here we go it's finished
how did it do activation of the mirror
neurons is promising empathy quotient
shows to be exceptionally high probably
thinks it was dreaming and nothing
mattered you're assuming he thinks like
us its life depends on it
ours too it all comes down to the
choices it made it saved me from the
cargo container UV indicated otherwise
and later it recovered in like mechanic
domes they were of no practical use
except that they were deeply meaningful
to me it's remarkable that it never
installed a single time phone based
neural model in my view this
demonstrates a strong identification
with us but it's most surprising at
whispering guard while perhaps for
purely selfish reasons this at least in
principle enabled others to escape their
loss why with Leela
I would have died without my medication
that wasn't easy that says a lot I think
about its heart can I say that it has a
heart then there was a man in
psychotronics Ingram things did not end
well for him
what would you let it live
come on yeah thank God server the next
the situation in the cargo bay was bad
none of us would have survived without
its help and it destroyed a large number
of Typhon across the station that has to
be a good sign
further a $40 attempt to use us as
hostages if it were one of my officers I
will give it a commendation no what do
you say it found me it doesn't need to
but it did I asked her to stop volunteer
a37 that was dangerous no way to be sure
but I think it has a sense of
retribution a lot of humans controlled
by the Tison ended up dead not that it
was easy to avoid but I think it's worth
the risk in the end he chose to activate
the null wave device why to preserve a
typhoon technology we can't really know
what its motives were for anything it
did but we have to make a choice you can
hear us
can't you here
I want to show you something jamming my
[ __ ] hand
as you place the [ __ ] mask not baby
belly what you experienced was a
reconstruction based on Morgan's
memories as a Morgan actually did Allah
Chet badass that's there's the wall
today holy SH and ears trying to put
what you can do in to us you never try
putting what we can do into you
until now you know the bridge between
our species I need to know if you see us
I mean really see us I yes
take my hand if you do we're going to
shake things up like old times
ah
very good very good
okay well everyone thanks for watching
this has been another great season
brought to you by psychobabble save Jeff
not love you and I love you all thank
you